[Music]
is that what you guys are always off-key
Shane Dawson yeah welcome back to the
Jillian podcast for another episode of
us being general Julianne and doing a
podcast I guess we're gonna do this
whole time my arm is already very tired
I think we might get demonetised for
just being gross stop guys this episode
is brought to you by the skin gets your
news from the free daily email
newsletter known as of this skin it is
amazing just fit into your routine with
coffee in the morning it helps you get
informed on what's going on in today in
the world without all the nonsense that
exists on the internet it's very concise
easy to read giving the information that
you need go to the skim th es ki mm Dom
/join it's completely free subscribe and
you're entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card also guys calm it is the app that
helps oh I love that app so much it
helps mindfulness it is just funny
barked at you while you did it but yes
it helps meditation guided meditation
I've been doing the daily calm as much
as I can I've not been doing it everyday
I will admit that but I'm doing a lot
and I really like it I popped my ear
pods in pressed daily calm and it's ten
minutes it's just it really is nice it's
an app that you can download right now
all right so go to see al m.com slash
Jenna Julian get 25% off premium
subscription when you use that URL more
on that later tell them what bunny did
we okay so we're gonna talk about buddy
first of all is that cool if my hair
looks like this because it's what it
looks like yes it's cool also that you
ask that question way too late because
if it wasn't cool we're already live
what about this you can hear her like
grumbling back there what I don't know
just checking to make sure every one day
I've been
trying to do calm like in the morning
sometimes I'll do it in the afternoon
but like if I can help it I'll wake up
and I'll sit up in bed as I'm like
drinking coffee or whatever drinking
water and she's kind of getting ready
for the day mentally to get out of bed
and if I need it I'll play I'll play the
daily calm and one day I was sitting in
bed you were asleep and I had woken hell
yeah and I play I didn't have my
headphones I was just playing it on my
phone and I was just sitting there doing
the daily comp and I you know you try to
shut your eyes while you're doing it
because you know it helps it helps with
the meditation and just kind of being
mindful of where your head is that and
everything so I'm sitting there like
this and the woman is guiding me through
the daily calming I'm like I'm feeling
so good I'm like the day's about to be
so good and then I just hear and I'm
like freaked out because I'm in this
like relaxed moment and it's allowed the
loudest most intense part and it was
funny because I like she saw because she
can see me in bed from her crate what
I'm sitting up when I laying down she
can't really see my head but yeah I feel
like I've already told her sorry today
no I don't know it was really funny
though you were you were like a
centrally meditating and closing your
eyes and she thought something was wrong
with you yeah she thought she had like
had never seen me with my eyes shot or
something I think I told this story on
the podcast am I crazy whatever anyway
that happened bunny has found herself
with a new injury a couple days ago we
were literally just about a start stream
who's the evening everything was normal
and Jenna calls me in either of the room
says look there's a bloody paw prints
around which dog is this we had just
eaten dinner and then we opened the
doors to like let them out and walk
around and stuff mm-hmm
and not even five minutes after I opened
the doors there's like bloody footprints
on the ground like what the hell is
going on in those five minutes yes then
Jenna deduced that it was coming from
Bunny's foot because she saw her foot
was a little bloodied up and so we
looked at it and first of all bunny has
been such a champ through this whole
thing and it's no surprise because she
is one of the strongest
and most resilient dogs I've ever met
but the whole time she has been so good
and there's been a really tough couple
of days it's been [ __ ] gnarly we
haven't really explained or shared
everything that's happened on the
internet cuz we just kind of been in
this world of like dealing with it
especially the first like 24 hours when
we got her back from the vet basically
she had stepped on something we didn't
know at the time we've since found out
what it was it was this piece of scrap
metal as sharp as a [ __ ] sitting
on the side of our house as she stepped
on and it cut like the wedding in her
paw and it was a bad cut it was like ah
yeah it was yeah it was a bad cut and we
were like we can't we can't just put a
bandage on it so we got to take her to
the vet so we took it it was the
emergency vet like yelping or in pain or
anything she was just walking around she
care less yeah and not only that she let
me look at it which is very good because
dogs can often snap or growl nasty so so
we took it about and they you know they
were like right we'll take her and we
handed her the lead no the woman the
leash and bunny was like okay and she
walked away with but the vet so well
like I mean Jenna has always said you
know greyhounds are notoriously good at
being handled by strangers because
that's kind of the life that they know
when they're racing or doing whatever
they're doing before they're adopted so
she goes off with the vet she calls us
in half an hour later updates us and
says hey it's not full-thickness the cut
which i think means it didn't like go
all the way through so we can just like
glue it up with some surgical glue and
clean it and you should be good and
turns out it was full thickness once
they cleaned it and she did need
stitches but they didn't have and they
didn't put her under which Jenna can get
into later but they stitched her foot up
drugged her up you know gave her a
little injection which I'm sure she
hated because that's what she's used to
is getting injections or needles and um
then we took her home and the last the
last like 24 hours we've gone through a
really really tough like realization
that she cannot wear a cone especially
with an injury because especially with
an injury and when she's on pain meds
the pain meds part she goes into a
deeper sleep and wait
up with more intense sleep startled now
that she's on the dresser she does have
sleep startled like for those of you
that watch our twitch stream you've
probably seen her at some point have a
sleep startled she's just laying there
she's relaxing and a lot of greyhounds
well not a lot but some of them can have
it it's common ground because what
happens is that when they're you know
kept as racing dogs or you know whatever
bunny was it's a long time until
someone's like touching them or near
them when they're sleeping you know
they're in a little crate or pen or
wherever they are and their food is
there's no one's touching them no one's
near them while they're sleeping it
takes a long time someone to come in the
building or turn the lights on or start
walking walking you here are there dogs
barking or getting excited there's like
a lot of time before anything is near
you while you're sleeping essentially so
for dogs that spend years in that
environment to be like on a dog bed you
know anything passing by or any noise or
something that just wakes them up out of
asleep their first reaction can be like
bark bark bark bark attack what is that
you know because it startles they're not
used to being vulnerable while they're
sleeping yeah it's like what marbles has
but it's actually a safety concern
because it's not marble right because I
have you touch marbles always sleeping
he wakes up barking wakes up barking
that's it's a that's a more intense
version of what bunny has but with the
drugs the pain meds I put her on it was
more intense because her sleep was
deeper and then when she woke up she was
more you know well and she had we had
the like hard plastic cone at the
recommendation of the vet which the vet
gave us a couple options yeah with her
stitches and the vet too honestly she
was one amazing yeah but one of the
options is to put her under to give her
stitches but that's like you know
greyhounds their bodies don't metabolize
the anesthesia the same ways of their
dog so it's important first of all that
that's like a last resort or something
that she's under right and that you have
a doctor that understands how to use
anesthesia on a greyhound but we didn't
have to do that thank God they were they
just gave her a local lidocaine and
stitched her up and she was a champ we
are like how did she do they were like
she barely even bited so then it was her
recommendation to use a hard cone which
we've used with the other dogs
permit when he was when he got fixed
when he was a baby like their faces are
so long
so his cone was like super long narrow
yeah I used to call it his avant-garde
cone because it was purple like toilet
paper roll and then marbles was like a
satellite dish like it was so so funny
but you know we've had experience with
the hard cones with the other dogs and
they well they're all I mean everything
about bunny has illuminated how freakin
easy these guys are but I mean it's not
that she's a difficult dog but like
things like that you would not really
think about like a cone and that being a
serious issue like these guys they have
cones but it's like who cares they're
fine they don't care
I remember when PG had her cone and she
just with like she would go onto the cup
first bit like as hard as she could
anyways it was the vets recommendation
to use the the plastic cone because her
face is so long if we put a soft cone on
her or something else it doesn't she can
still get to it or easily work around
him even with the plastic cone there
were parts of her bandage that she could
still easily get to because she's just
has a long face and neck you know no and
we brought her home and she was drugged
well first of all when we picked her up
at the vet you know you could tell
instantly she's back in that 100%
fight-or-flight trauma mode that we got
her in yeah there is no like she doesn't
make eye contact she doesn't respond it
was like right when we adopted her sort
of you know she wasn't freaking out I
mean she knew who we were but there was
no there was no bloody personality yes
she's back in the like I'm just trying
to get through this moment in this
moment in this moment which was really
it was just hard to see her like that
again and you know I was yesterday I was
like is she just gonna regress back into
this like space you know and feel like
she's not coming home or is she gonna go
somewhere else
no and we brought her home with the cone
and we had her lay down for a little
choose doing okay yeah and then she had
it's like a terrible sleep startled it
was the next was the next like morning
we were hanging out and we were we had
the cone on she it was brutal but she
got through the first night with a cone
on she's kind of stood in her crate for
like an hour until I went over there and
I actually like laid her down for her
because she was like delirious on drugs
and also in this crate which it's the
excel crate it's the biggest crate we
could buy with our money dollars but she
still somehow fills it out especially
with that cone it was tight in there and
so I finally laid her down she she made
it through the night there's anything
that touches it she starts freaking yeah
cuz it makes a noise and then she's like
what was that and so the next morning
we're hanging out in the game room cuz
that's like her room that's her happy
place so we're just sitting in our
computers we're both kind of just like
they're hanging and something wakes her
up and she wakes up and here's the
counter feels the cone or here's the
cone of something and the cone drives
her to literally run out the room and
like leap into the wall yeah sure jumped
into the wall it was like [ __ ] gnarly
because she was so scared and didn't
know what was getting her and what I
mean she was just totally freaked out oh
yeah if you if you have sleep startled
as it is and then you wake up and
something's around your head and neck
like she literally thinks her life is
over yes so she was like full force into
the world freak out jumps into the wall
and then runs through the house leaving
a trail of like poop she literally was
pooping she was like nervous because
she's a nervous farter like that's what
she does when she's nervous she like
farts and this was like a really intense
version of that and so oh my god it's
like the hardest thing to ever watch
because like not only is that
traumatizing to see your dog do that but
she's running and jumping and freaking
up on this bottom leg yeah I'm we're
like god this is just so bad man and so
after that we were like no Collin no
cone there's no and not only not only
that is like a hundred percent that
event means no cone because if we can't
go through that again she can't go
through that again
but she hadn't even attempted to like go
for the wound and so the cone I get
that's that's the purpose it serving but
she was so like not present that she was
like you know normal bunny would be like
yeah what's this
I'm gonna lick it off but she's not
normal bunny she's like in trauma state
so we took off the cone and we figured
if we're directly supervising her she
doesn't need anything she was not going
for it yeah and if we're leaving the
room we put on her muzzle cuz we've
trained her with her muzzle a lot and
she's comfortable with it yeah yeah they
know it she was comfortable with it when
we got her yeah anyway that brings us to
today today's the first day she's wagged
her tail since the whole thing much
happier when she woke up today I've been
carrying her up and down the stairs just
so she doesn't have to you know the that
was like no exercise no excess movement
just really try to keep her off the foot
so as where we are we it's been a wild
couple days but you guys have sent a lot
of really nice tweets so thank you for
that and their concern and nice comments
you've left she's a champ I mean there's
no other way to put it she's she's
handling this like an absolute champ but
it's also it's like it's a good
experience for us to have because I mean
I feel like I've always been this way
with the little ones it's like your dog
or your pet you know the vet can give
you the best advice that they can but at
the end of the day you know them
probably better than anyone and I think
a cone obviously works for a lot of I
per centage of dogs you know and a lot
of people try and do a soft one or one
of the inflatable ones but like it's a
safety hazard for her way more than her
bandage ever like she could break her
one of her legs or like her own neck
from jumping into a wall like that like
at the end of the day you just have to
you know figure out what's best for your
pet even if the vet is like no you need
this hard cone I'm like girl I think I'm
gonna take it off today yeah I don't
think we're ever gonna put a cone back I
mean and the weirdest part about the
whole thing is that the stitches and the
cut she got is like the least
it's the throughout this whole thing has
been the least of our problems mm-hmm
you know like yeah she's going light on
that foot and kind of limping at this
point cuz it's probably a little painful
but it's the cone it's the drugs it's
the vet experience it's all of that that
was like the hardest part you know the
actual injury isn't that bad
so it was the first time though we had
taken her to the vet so it was I think
all things considered it's a I don't
know I don't want it I don't want it to
sound wrong but it's like she had a cut
she's okay and our first time to the vet
is something that like true you know not
overly traumatized and it's the cone has
been John that's true and it's like one
of those things like when you adopt an
animal the last thing you want to do
especially when they come from trauma
you don't ever want to bring them with
the vet if you don't have to so it like
you idealize in your moment when your
mind like the first chapter that will be
nice that's not how it works out and
actually today for you guys tomorrow for
us we're gonna be taking her to the vet
to get the pen is removed and checked up
on yeah and I've seen a lot of people
comment to that with greyhounds
specifically if you put a baby sock on
either on the the foot that is affected
so that they're like what's this I don't
like this I don't want to chew it it's
just bothering me
or I read that some people put the baby
sock on the other foot because then it
distracts your Greyhound enough I'm
going up there yeah and we'll probably
we'll probably keep it covered for she
can't walk gone walks for like seven
days let me hide another couple days
she'll have the sutures taken out means
that walk men she does need my walk but
that I will say the pain meds are
keeping her kind of sedated yeah but
it's just been yesterday was incredibly
difficult but um it's just overall kind
of hard to see her like that in general
and it feels like so unfair you know we
have a pretty big yard and it's not like
we're constantly going out there and
combing it for pieces of metal
it just feels unfair and it feels unfair
that it had to happen to her and it's
frustrating when all of a sudden you
just routinely let your dog out into
your own yard and they come back with a
terrible cut it just it makes you feel
guilty and like sad and it just [ __ ]
sucks like I wish it didn't happen to
her like she doesn't deserve that ever
again she doesn't deserve to feel like I
need to heal right now yeah but I mean
all things considered like you said you
know it wasn't that bad
and looking back on this months from now
she's going to be a better off animal
because of it it's like an experience
that's going to help her and I know that
sounds [ __ ] but it's like life like
it's super random what happened but the
way she's dealt with it and her getting
through it and her coming out the other
end like RT wagging her tail
two days later like she got excited
because she saw lexi - yeah we had a
friend over but she came over but anyway
Bunny's doing great she's resting she's
not we almost had an issue with peach
this morning oh my god Julian was giving
bunny her pain meds and bunny so smart
so she just eats around the payments and
spits out the pain meds so Julian was
breaking it up and mixing it in with her
food like pieces of pill pocket with the
boot so that he can try and trick her
and it's not really working and bunny
sort of like turns around and Julian you
know goes to grab her and bring her back
and within two seconds the silent peach
ninja walks in there dips her head in
and starts eating only the pill pockets
obviously because she loves them and all
of a sudden Julian is like did she eat
those does she eat those and I'm like I
don't know I just like grabbed her as
fast as I could and I didn't realize
that he had put the painkillers in the
bowl I thought that was just her food I
thought peach was just eating Bunny's
food and Julian's like no that's that's
the tramadol that's you know the pink oh
my god that's like 50 milligrams to try
at all so we had to call the vet and be
like you know can you help us do the
math is this like a lethal dose like do
we need to go get her stomach pumped but
we don't even know if she ate it or not
like we don't know which dog just took
this painkiller oh man we definitely
don't think that she took it he just
completely 100% I think she might have
had like a little little chip of it but
no she didn't and the vet said it was a
fine dose it's just a heavy dose for her
but she'd be fine and I think judging by
Bunny's behavior more so I think bunny
took the most of it but I was [ __ ]
terrifying like jeez can you guys just
like [ __ ] she's gonna well first of
all the little three men like I love
them to death but god damn it everything
has to be about them and when bunny was
going through this whole thing there
in the way they're jumping on her bed
they're smelling her they're just in our
face they when I'm trying to feed bunny
when she's like drugged out they're like
oh food and they're like chasing her
food I mean they are like everything's
about them and I caught peach the other
day I heard a noise so I go to the room
where we feed bunny and she looks like
she's about to dive into Bunny's food
bucket like a pool she's standing up
like a person in her hands she opened it
she opens the locked food container the
big-ass lock it's up and she just she's
just sitting there and I'm like and she
had actually eaten a fair bit of it by
that point so I picked her up and I felt
like I was holding two dogs and so yeah
that's been that's been just like when
we went to go out and we called the
nuumber we literally walk out the front
door you can still see in the house we
can see in the window it's this second
we walk into the front yard peach trots
into the office but she can't see out
the window cuz there's a glare so we're
looking right at her she rots over to
your backpack slowly pulls out an entire
bag of pistachios and starts walking
over to current like hey Sam it's mommy
and daddy agon got our pistachio
[Laughter]
activity for us to do you open I eat the
salmon and I'm like to draw my peach my
pistachios but that's what she does she
like she's she like filters away things
she logs yeah she has like a little mini
heat map and she just waits until the
perfect moment and it's like yeah I mean
her memory 90% is is this like
infrastructure she's built in her brain
to remember locations of obscure food
that she could take it's just like it's
wild we shut the door and she just was
already in your back sticks her whole
head they can open the pantry door I
mean oh this is just you know what we've
been having to religiously keep the
pantry door like all the way otherwise
she's a bunny with that we were so
concerned that bunny was gonna figure
out how to go in the pantry and steal
stuff because she's so tall it's peach
if it's open like a tiny little sliver
from home and there's a whole bag of
chips on the couch did she like I don't
know how
she doesn't but she opens it from like
the mouth uh the handle is way higher
than she can get so it's all just like
nudging the door or she probably can
pull it open with her foot or something
because it doesn't you know you close it
and it's sort of like one of those doors
that just like sort of shot like it's
more like a cupboard kind of door it
doesn't like latch so you have to turn
the door handle yeah that's just like
shuts so she probably could figure out
how to just pull the bottom because I'm
we're always like did you leave it open
did you leave it open I'm like no no I
closed that but you have to like fully
[ __ ] open it we eventually need to
like zip tie it or something there like
to have a baby lock on a baby lot
because peach is a baby anyway I don't
know about you but after this weekend I
could definitely use some daily comm
just don't do it well Bunny's looking at
you use calm to relax yourself and be
mindful and meditate but don't do it
when your dogs are looking at you
because they might bark at you that's
that's my little side note about calm
but if you're looking to get into some
sort of basic meditation or even just
like take a moment away from your busy
day off your phone off your devices just
to like reset and be a little bit
focused on what's going on in your brain
it makes a massive difference this is
something that I I I'm personally
vouching for because I use this I try to
use it regularly but I also resort to it
in moments of stress and when I know
that I need to just like put things away
and just kind of calm down for a sec
hence the name I log on to the comma I
put in my headphones and I do the daily
comm and it is just something that it's
very easy to do but when you realize
what it's doing for you it you realize
how kind of powerful it is to just take
that time out of your day to really kind
of just invest in yourself a little bit
it's also really great for falling
asleep it's an amazing tool to help you
settle down to wind down for the day and
get yourself ready for sleep because
it's it's hard sometimes to not go from
screen screen screen sleep because
that's kind of what I do sometimes
that's what you do it's what we all do
so calm is really good for helping you
get sleep be mindful and over
I'll just improve your quality of life
so if you want to seize the day sleep
the night get the help of calm go to
calm calm / annejulien
and join over 40 million people that are
downloaded also guys when you're waking
up in the morning after your nice
night's sleep from calm get filled in on
what's going on on today's world with
the skin the skin is a free newsletter
that comes into your email very concise
easy to read with just kind of the
bullet points of what's going on just to
help you be aware and in the know about
important news stories that you should
know for your own benefit also you can
dominate where conversations that work
at the water cooler just destroy it
Karen okay you just sign up you enter
your email and then every morning they
send you what you need to know there's
no nonsense there's no fillers there's
no opinions it's just here's what's
happening in the world and a very easy
to read easy to digest format take it
enjoy it do what you will with it but
here it is now you are smarter and
educated go on and and seize the day
also when you sign up you're enter to
win a two hundred and fifty dollar Visa
gift card that's completely free that
you could win money and you can spend it
on whenever you want spend that on a dog
you spend on a dog collar he's been that
on a comprar Miam subscription anyway
those are our sponsors click the links
below so check them out on warm
stressful a couple days but it's good
now good I think I think I hope not come
wet knock on wood someone told us they
wanted us to read creepypasta can I just
explain what creepypasta creepypasta is
the weirdest combination of words I've
ever heard I'm sorry
it just sounds weird so basically it's
like horror based oh that have spread
around the internet from people copy and
pasting which I think the last part of
the word is that what pasta means like
paste you know I don't know the answer
to that but can i play some royalty-free
scary music because there's like copy
pasta and then this is creepypasta I
don't know
I found a letter from my stalker oh man
these are crazy so I sorted by most
popular on creepypasta calm a shattered
life so they're pretty long we might
only have time for one I don't know okay
I'm just gonna start reading and see
what happens I'll play some great music
Jesus I don't think I like this find a
song that's that's good or else I can't
it's got to be good or else I can't
listen to this story
you know for sure
why is my browser being so slow anyway
so it's like paranormal horror fiction
scaring you since 2008 this is good this
is good music user generated so most of
them are like fictional or whatever I
think they're all fictional actually is
Shane Dawson video
[Music]
for whatever reason my browser just
literally stopped working hold on mmm
this is a good melody hmm mm-hmm
creepypasta let's try this is it the
website maybe I don't know this is a
good song okay do you hear it yeah here
I'm just trying to wow it's really good
well I'm sorry for the delay give me one
sec do you want to use my phone maybe I
mean I don't know if it's the website or
like what's happening it's literally
just not loading
you should get an older iPhone probably
your iPhone sucks why'd you show off my
music it should play in the background
why don't you have that set to play the
better I do but you changes songs what
ancient feudal Japan this is not what I
signed up for I mean that's incredibly
interesting I am down to watch it some
other time but I was listening to
royalty free copyright free creepy music
yeah you okay you got it out of your
system this is not the song that I chose
it changed what do you mean it is the
song he chose did you put on playlist or
you just know I literally I went back to
the video game this website is not
working it's just little this decided
okay I'm scared in general like just
about life you know all right what cut
what what what genre classics monsters
dream / sleep haunted television items
and objects places dismemberment okay
not that dismemberment no orange juice
remember me I'm gonna throw up
how about dreams in sleep just not
dismemberment
I actually pass out like I can't rake I
can't hear about that stuff
I'm scared right so this is hold on I'm
just
this is creepypasta the wiki so I think
this is I'm scared it's it's using like
dates and stuff it's called the rake
look at the picture wait let me see oh
no wait I don't stop it move I can't see
I really don't like that picture I
really don't like that picture Julien it
really scares me during the summer of
2003 events in the northeastern United
States involving a strange human-like
creature sparked brief local media
interest before an apparent blackout was
enacted little or no information was
left intact as most online and written
accounts of the creature were
mysteriously destroyed primarily focused
in rural New York State rural New York
State and once found in Idaho
self-proclaimed witnesses told stories
of their encounters with a creature of
unknown origin can we play more music
what the heck man emotions ranged from
extremely traumatic levels of fright and
discomfort to an almost childlike sense
of playfulness and curiosity excuse me
while their published versions are no
longer on record the memories remained
powerful several of the involved parties
began looking for answers that year in
early 2006 the collaboration had
accumulated nearly two dozen documents
dating between the 12th century and
priests and present-day spanning four
continents in almost all cases the
stories were identical I've been in
contact with a member of this group and
was able to get some expert excerpts
from the upcoming book are these real
stories a suicide note
1964 as I prepare to take my life I feel
it necessary to it
Asajj any guilt or pain I have
introduced through this
it is not the fault of anyone other than
him do we need to do like some sort of
warning if I'm talking about suicide
notes here
trigger warning I'll probably just say
it to be safe trigger warning this this
next part is about suicide it's maybe
someone in the comments can put like a
time stamp or something when the it's
safe to listen to again yeah this this
looks all be fictional just keep that in
mind anyway
for once I awoke and felt his presence
and once I awoke and saw his form once
again I awoke and heard his voice and
looked into his eyes I cannot sleep
without fear of what might make to
experience what I might next awake to
experience her I can never I cannot ever
awake goodbye found in the same wooden
box where two empty envelopes addressed
to William in rows and one loose
personal letter with no envelope dearest
lynnie I've prayed for you he spoke your
name a journal entry translated from
Spanish I have experienced the greatest
terror I have experienced the greatest
terror I have experienced the greatest
terror I see his eyes when I close mine
they are hollow black they saw me and
pierced me Oh
his wet hand Julien I will not sleep his
voice has to be wet unintelligible text
why does his hand have to be wet a
Mariners log nineteen sixteen ninety-one
he came to me and in my sleep from the
foot of my bed I felt a suspense
sensation
wait no now I have to be afraid of my
bed he took everything we must return to
England
we must not return here again at the
request of the rake the rate kids what
they call it from a witness 2006 three
years ago I had returned five six I had
returned from a trip from Niagara Falls
with my family for the fourth of July Oh
the Canadian side is so much better
Weaver we were all very exhausted after
a long day of driving so my husband and
I put the kids right to bed
and called it a night at about 4 a.m. I
woke up thinking my husband had gotten
up to use the restroom
I used the moment to steal back the
sheets only to wake him up in the
process
I apologize to him and told him I
thought he got out of bed when he turned
to me and faced me he gasped and pulled
his feet up from the end of the bed so
quickly his knee almost knocked me out
of the bed then he grabbed me and said
nothing after adjusting for the to the
dark for a half a second I was able to
see what caused a strange reaction at
the foot of the bed sitting facing away
from us there was what appeared to be a
naked man okay or a large hairless dog
of some sort its body position was
disturbing and unnatural as if as if it
had been hit by a car or something for
some reason I was not instantly
frightened by it but more concerned as
to its condition at this point I was
somewhat under the assumption that we
were supposed to help him my husband was
peering over his arm and knee tucked
into the fetal position occasionally
glancing at me before returning to the
creature in a flurry of motion the
creature scrambled around the side of
the bed then crawled quickly in a
flailing sort of motion right along the
bed until it was less than a foot away
from my husband's face the creature was
completely silent for about 30 seconds
or probably closer to five it just
seemed like a while just looking at my
husband the creature then placed its
hand on his knee and ran into the
hallway leading into the kids rooms I
screamed and ran for the light switch
planning to stop him before you hurt my
children when I got to the hallway the
light from my bedroom was enough to see
it crouching and hunched over about 20
feet away he turned around and looked
directly at me covered in blood
I flipped the switch on the wall and saw
my daughter Clara the the creature ran
down the stairs while my husband and I
rushed to help our daughter she was very
badly injured and spoke to us spoke only
once more in her short life she said he
is the rake
my husband drove his car to the lake
that night while rushing our daughter
the hospital they did not survive what
being in a small town news got around
pretty quickly
the police were helpful at first and the
local newspaper took a lot of interest
as well however the story was never
published and local television news
never followed up either so the husband
and the daughter died mm-hmm
it took the four of us about two solid
years of hunting on the Internet and
writing letters to come up with a small
collection of what we believe to be the
accounts of the rake none of them give
any details history or follow up one
journal entry involved the creature in
its first three pages and then never
mention it again a ship's log explained
nothing of the encounter saying that
they were told to leave by the rake that
was the last entry in the log they were
however there were however many
instances when the creatures visit was
one of a series of visits with the same
person okay no no you're not gonna come
back here and come back you with that
wet head come back here with that wet
hand wait so he just randomly chooses a
person let's just think about this for
one second so we don't know if these
stories are true or not they're not
really definitely not true that this
slimy naked man plenty jus just chooses
someone's bed room to just show up
butt-ass naked in and then kill and he
he wants to kill kids too
I can see an email happening from this
I'm scared okay I'm like jet like part
of that story was making me physically
nauseous like I'm getting [ __ ] scared
[ __ ] off come on and I particularly do
not like the description of his wet hand
he's wet hey I want none of that
sentence all right that was 2006 and I
Agri Falls I feel like I would have
heard about it I called malarkey um I
forget if I read this part but I stayed
at a hotel near my parents house after
we decided to term I began looking for
answers myself yeah yeah yeah okay we
read that part there were however many
instances of multiple businesses in
person yeah multiple people also
mentioned to me multiple people also
mention being spoken to my daughter
included this led to uh this led us to
wonder if the rake had visited any of us
before our last encounter I set up a
digital recorder named I don't kill them
I said up a digital recorder near my bed
I left it running all night every night
for two weeks I would de Deus Li scan
through the sounds of the of me rolling
through the bed each day when I woke up
he got into a program and see if there's
any peaks in the audio no they had to do
Ltd asleep okay get out of here with
that logic by the end of the second week
I was quite used to the occasional sound
of sleep well blurring through the sound
the recording at 8 times the normal
speed this almost took an hour every day
oh wow so much work you're making fun of
a fictional person's going through
fictional audio on the first day of the
third week I thought I heard something
different what I found was a shrill
voice it was the rake I can't listen to
it long enough to even begin to
transcribe it I haven't let anyone else
listen to it yet all I know is that I've
heard it before and I now believe it
spoke when I was when I was sitting in
front of my husband I don't remember
hearing anything at the time but for
some reason the voice on the recorder
immediately brings me back to that
moment
the thoughts that have must gone through
my daughter's head make me very upset I
have not seen the rake since he ruined
my life but I know that he has been in
my room while I slept
oh [ __ ] no I know and fear that one
night I'll wake up to see him staring at
me done done at the end that was it
thank God that was the way also that
means wet hand I really have on the
category page there's one of those
disappearances but it spelled
disappearances this opinions
disappearances maybe you want some
disappearance I'm just checking to see
if the other web page is still down and
it is so let's check it a different one
classics let's go to classics that's not
the Russian sleep experiment okay wait
wait what didn't I think I'm rid of that
have you I think I've heard that one yes
can I read it or okay well if you've
heard it I mean it just sounds
interesting yeah I've definitely heard
this we might have even done this one on
the podcast or talked about it on then
in in an attempt to not do the same
thing twice yes we'll do a different one
Ben drowned
Squidward's suicide were they okay
there's a well-known creepypasta and
later an alternate reality game known as
the Jade ossible the story revolves
around Majora's Mask cartridge cartridge
that is haunted by the ghost of if it is
a ghost the bunny who's been this about
today this is about video I was just
reading the quick synopsis it's about
video games a video game cartridge
Majora's Mask okay I'll read it
September 10th 7th 2010 almost my
birthday coming up the anniversary is
coming up deep in Virgo season okay go
on I'm listening
okay X I need your help with this this
is not my this is not copypasta this is
a long read oh god wait let me just
check holy God okay are we in for this
or okay how long is it let's go yeah
[ __ ] you know just be along read it's a
long read but I feel like my safety or
well-being could very well depend on
this okay this is a video game related
specifically Majora's Mask this is the
[ __ ] that has ever happened to me in my
entire life what's majora's mask that a
real game I think it's a Zelda game I've
never played I think it's a Zelda game I
could be wrong and it could be upsetting
everybody I could also be upsetting
everybody by not knowing for sure that
it's a Zelda game either way I apologize
oh my phone is a 10% battery if we don't
get to why do you know charge your phone
obviously like other people what playing
hearthstone yeah how do i spell majora's
mask maj ori having said that i recently
moved in Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask I
recently moved into my dorm room
starting as a sophomore in college and a
friend of mine gave me his old and 64 to
play I was stoked to say the least I
could finally play all those games with
my youth that I hadn't touched in at
least a decade same his n64 came with
one yellow controller and a rather
shoddy cop copy of Super Smash Brothers
fine
and while beggars can't be choosers
needless to say it didn't take long if
they'll be I I became bored of beating
up level 9 CPUs dance guys owning
you're not the Flex honestly that that
weekend I decided to drive around a few
neighborhoods about 20 minutes or so off
campus hitting up the local garage sales
hoping to screw on some good deals from
ignorant parents okay I was thinking
that I don't really like this person I
ended up picking up a copy of Pokemon
Stadium Goldeneye [ __ ] yeah f-zero and
two other controllers for two dollars
satisfied I began to drive out of my
other neighborhood when one last house
caught my attention I still have no idea
why it did there were no cars there and
only one table was set up with random
junk on it but something sort of drew me
there I usually trust my gut on these
things so I got out of the car and I was
greeted by an old man his outward
appearance was for lack of a better word
displeasing it was odd if you asked me
to tell you why I thought he was
displeasing I couldn't really pinpoint
anything there was just something about
him that put me on edge I can't explain
it all I can tell you is that if it
wasn't in the middle of the afternoon
and there were other people within
shouting distance I would not have even
thought of approaching this man he
flashed a crooked smile at me and asked
what I was looking for and immediately I
noticed that he must be blind in one of
his eyes don't Godzilla his right I had
this glazed over look about it I forced
myself to look into his left eye trying
not to offend and asked him if he had
any old video games
I was already wondering how I could
politely excuse myself from the
situation when he was when he would tell
me that he had no video games or didn't
know what they were but to my surprise
he said he had a few ones in an old box
he assured me that he'd be back in a
jiffy and turned to head back to his
garage as I watched him hobble away I
couldn't help but notice what he was
selling on his table littered across the
table were rather peculiar paintings
various artworks that look like ink
blots that a psychiatrist might show you
like Rorschach hmm you get that joke
that's nice you get that reference yes
they do
curious I looked through them it was
obvious why no one was visiting this
guy's garage sale sounds like it [ __ ]
sucked
these weren't exactly aesthetically
pleasing as I came to the last one for
some reason it looked almost like
Majora's Mask the same heart-shaped body
with a
Spike's protruding outward initially I
thought it was that since I was secretly
hoping to find that game in garage sale
some Freudian [ __ ] was projecting
itself onto the in pots I don't think
that's how that works
but given the events that happened
afterward I'm not so sure I should have
asked this man about it I wish I would
have asked this man about it
after staring at the majora I looked up
in the old man was suddenly there again
his arm arm's length in front of me
smiling at me I'll admit I jumped out of
reflex and laugh nervously as he handed
me a Nintendo 64 cartridge it was a
standard gray color except that someone
had written majora on it in the back in
permanent marker uh in black permanent
marker sorry I got butterflies in my
stomach cuz I realized what coincidence
this was and I asked him how much you
wanted for it the old man smiled at me
and told me that I could have it for
free that it used to belong to a kid who
was about my age that didn't live here
anymore there's something weird about
how he phrased that but I didn't really
pay attention to it then I was too
caught up in only finding this game not
only finding this game but getting it
for [ __ ] free let's go let's go why
don't you just buy it online if you
wanted that bad it was in 2010 yeah ah
we had we have [ __ ] eBay [ __ ] back
in 2010 I reminded myself to be a bit
skeptical since this looked like a
pretty shady cartridge and there's no
guarantee it would work but then blow on
it blow inside rejected that maybe it
was some kind of beta version or pirated
version of global beta love a beta blow
on that beta version Wow and that always
needed and that that was all I needed to
be back on cloud nine I think the man
and the man smiled at me and wish me
well saying goodbye then at least that's
what it sounded like to me all the way
in my car ride home I had a nagging
doubt that the man had said something
else my fears were confirmed when I
booted up the game to my surprise that
worked just fine and there was one save
file name simply Ben could buy Ben he
was saying he was saying goodbye Ben I
felt that I did too I felt bad for the
man
obviously a grandparent are obviously
going senile I for some reason or
another reminded him of his grandson Ben
oh my god that cream you know out of
curiosity I looked at the safe file
eyeballing it I could tell he was pretty
far out of the game he had almost all
the masks and three-four remains of the
bosses I noticed that he had yeah she's
good I noticed that he had on an owl
statue to save his game he was on day
three and by the stone tower temple with
hardly an hour left before the moon
would crash I remember thinking that it
was a shame that he had come so close to
be in the game but he never finished it
I made a new file named link out of
tradition and starting the game ready to
relive my childhood for such a shady
looking game cartridge I was impressed
at how smoothly it ran literally just
like a retail copy of the game save for
a few minor hiccups here and there like
textures being where they shouldn't be
random flashes of cutscenes at odd
intervals but nothing too bad however
the only thing that was a little
unnerving was that at times that NPCs
would call me linked and at other times
they would call me Ben
okay you know what I figured it was just
a bug a fluke in the programming causing
our files to get mixed up or something
did kind of creeped me out though after
a while and it was around after I had be
beaten the would fall temple that I
regrettably went into the save files and
deleted Ben I had intended to preserve
the file just out of respect for the
game's original owner it's not like I
needed two files anyway hoping that it
wouldn't it would solve the problem it
did and it didn't now NPCs wouldn't call
me anything where my name should be in
the dialog box there was just a blank
space my save file was still called link
though frustrated and with homework to
do I put the game down for a day I
started playing the game again last
night getting the lens of truth and
working my way towards completing the
Snowhead temple now some of you are more
hardcore Majora's Mask players and Noah
on the fourth day glitch means bug for
those who don't you can google it but
the gist of it is that rise the clocks
about to hit zero
zero zero zero zero in the final day you
talk to the astronomer and look through
the telescope if you time it right the
countdown disappears and you essentially
have another day to finish whatever you
were doing deciding to do the glitch and
try to finish the Snowhead temple I
happened to get it right on the first
try and the timer count disappeared
however when I press B to exit the
telescope instead of being greeted by
the astronomer I found myself in the
majora fight room at the end of the game
the trippy boxed-in arena
staring at Skull Kid hovering above me
there was no sound just him floating in
the air above me and the background
music was which was regular for the area
but still creepy immediately my palms
began to sweat this was definitely not
normal school kid never appeared here I
tried moving around the area no matter
where I went what he was just shaking
the whole room oh no am i nervously
doing them I don't care it's I have to
nothing would happen and this kept up
for around 60 seconds I thought the game
was bugged or something but I was
beginning to doubt that very much I was
about to reach for the reset button when
text appeared on my screen you're not
sure why but you apparently had a
reservation I instantly recognized that
text you get that message when you get
the room key from Anju at the stockpot
in but why was it playing here I refuse
to entertain the notion that it was
almost as if the game was trying to
communicate with me I started to
navigate the room again testing to see
if it was some sort of trigger that
enabled me to interact with something
here then I realized how stupid I was to
even think that someone could reprogram
the game like that was absurd sure
enough 15 seconds later another message
appeared on the screen and again like
the first one it was already a
pre-existing phrase go to the lair of
the temples boss yes or no I pause for a
second contemplating what should I press
and how would the game react when I
realized that I couldn't select No
taking a deep breath I pressed yes and
the screen faded to white with the words
dawn of a new day and the subtext
looks like uh like I capital I like five
times or six times beneath it or just
Lions I don't know if their lands okay
no I can't stop doing I can't stop
shaking my legs shaking the entire room
no no yes you are
I'm nervous let me be nervous Oh fine
I'll stop where I was ported to Phil
where I was ported to filled me next
where I was ported to filled me next
with the most intense sense of dread and
impounding fear impending fear I'd ever
experienced the only way I could
describe the way I felt here is having
this feeling of inexplicable
inexplicable depression on a profound
scale I'm not normally a depressed
person but the way I felt here was a
feeling that I didn't even know existed
he was such a twisted powerful presence
that seemed to wash over me
I appeared in some kind of Twilight Zone
version of Clock Town I walked out of
the clock tower as you normally do when
you start day one only to find out that
all the inhabitants were gone usually
with the fourth day glitch you can still
find the guards and the dogs that run
around the tower this time they were all
gone
what replaced them was the ominous
feeling that there was something out
there in the same area as me and that it
was watching me I had four hearts to my
name than the hero's bow but at this
point I wasn't even considered
I wasn't even considered for my avatar
concern maybe he meant I don't know yeah
I felt that personally I was in some
kind of danger perhaps the most chilling
thing was the music it was the song of
healing ripped straight from the game
itself but played in Reverse okay [ __ ]
that the music would get louder building
up so so if you should expect something
to pop out in front of you but nothing
ever did and the constant loop began to
wear my mental state every now and then
I would hear the faint laugh of the
happy mask salesman in the background
just quiet enough so that I wasn't sure
if I was hearing things but it just loud
enough to keep me determined to find him
I looked in all four zones of Clock Town
only to find nothing no one
textures were missing West clock town
had me walking on air the entire area
felt broken hopelessly broken
as the reverse song of healing repeated
for what it must have been the 50th time
I just remember standing in the middle
of Clock Town realizing that I had never
felt so alone in a video game before as
I walked through the ghost town I don't
know whether it was a combination of the
out-of-place textures in the atmosphere
and the haunting melody of the once
peaceful and soothing song being
butchered and distorted but I was
literally on the verge of tears and I
had no idea why I hardly ever cry
something had gripped me here and was so
powerful that this sense of depression
was both foreign and crippling I tried
leaving clock down but every time I
attempted to zone out the screen would
fade to black and I was just sewn into
another part of clock town I tried
playing my ocarina
I wanted to escape I did not want to be
here but every time I played the song of
time or the song of soaring it would say
your notes echo far but nothing happens
by this point I was obvious that the
game didn't want me to leave but I had
no idea why I was keeping me here I
didn't want to go inside the buildings I
felt that I would be too vulnerable to
whatever was terrifying me I don't know
why but I came up with this idea that
maybe if I drown myself in the laundry
pool I could spawn somewhere else and
leave this place as I zoned in and ran
towards the pool that's when it happened
Linc grabbed his head the screen flashed
for a brief moment of the happy mask
salesman smiling at me not linked me
with skull kids scream playing in the
background and when the screen returned
I was staring at the Linc statue from
playing the song elegy elegy elegy of
emptiness I screamed as the thing just
stared back to me with that haunting
facial expression I turned around and
ran back out of South clock town and to
my horror the [ __ ] statue followed me
the only way I could compare this is
like the weeping angels from Doctor Who
don't don't know what that is every so
often at random intervals and animation
would play the statue appearing behind
me it was like this thing was chasing me
or I don't even want to say it was
haunting me by this point I was on the
verge of hysterics not once did the
thought of turning off the console occur
to me I don't know why I was so wrapped
up in it
felt so real I tried to shake the statue
but it would literally appear right
behind me every single time
link started to begin to make weird
animations I had never seen him do
before it he would flail his arms around
her spasm
randomly the screen would cut to the
happy mask salesman smiling again for a
brief moment before I was face to face
with that [ __ ] statue again I ended
up running down the swords master doubt
running into the swords master dojo and
ran into the back I don't know why but
my panic I just wanted some kind of
assurance that I'm not alone here to my
dismay I found no one but as I turned to
leave the statue cornered me in the
cubby in the back I tried attacking the
statue with my sword but to no avail
confused and backed into a corner I
started staring at the statue waiting
for it to kill me suddenly the screen
flashed again to the happy mask salesman
and Link turned my face turned to my
face screen standing upright mirroring
the statue looking at me along with his
copy literally staring at me whatever
was left of the fourth wall was
completely shattered when while I ran
out of the dojo terrified some suddenly
the game warped me to an underground
tunnel and the reverse song of healing
queued up again as I was given a brief
moment of rest before the statue started
appearing behind me this time
aggressively I could only take a few
steps now before he would summon behind
me again
I hurried and made my way out of the
tunnel and appeared in Clock Town as I
ran aimlessly in sheer panic suddenly a
red a redead screamed and faded to black
as the dawn of the day and the III
appeared again the screen faded in and I
was standing on top of clock tower with
Skull Kid hovering over me silent I
looked up and the moon was back looming
just meters above my head but the Skull
Kid just stared at me hauntingly with
that [ __ ] mask a new song was playing
the stone tower temple theme played in
Reverse in some sort of desperate
attempt I equipped my bow and fired off
a shot at Skull Kid and it actually hit
him and he played the animation of him
reeling back I fired again and on the
third arrow a text box appeared saying
that won't do any good here hehe
I was picked up off the ground levitated
on my back and then links screams as he
bursts into flames instantly killing him
I jumped when this happened I had never
seen anyone used this move on anyone in
the game and Skull Kid himself didn't
even have the moves as the death screen
played my lifeless body was still
burning Skull Kid laughed and the screen
faded to black only to have me reappear
in the same place I've decided to charge
him but the same thing happened links
body was lifted off the ground and some
known unknown force immediately burst
him into flames again killing him this
time the death screen play the faint
sounds of this reverse song of healing
that could be heard on my third and
final try I noticed that there was no
music playing this time all that there
was was this eerie silence and I
remember that the original encounter was
Skull Kid you were supposed to use the
ocarina to either travel back in time or
summon the Giants I attempted to play
the song of time before I could hit the
last note only the last note links body
once again horrific aleus exploded into
flames and he died as the death screen
neared its end I began to chug as if the
cartridge is trying to process a lot of
something when the screen came to it was
the same scene as the first three times
except this time link was lying on the
ground dead in a position I had never
seen in the game before his head tilted
towards the camera with the Skull Kid
floating above him I couldn't move I
couldn't press any buttons I could do
was stare at links dead body after
around 30 seconds of this the game
simply fades out with the message you've
met with a terrible fate haven't you
before kicking you out to the title
screen upon getting back to the title
screen and starting again I noticed my
save file was no longer there instead of
link it was replaced with your turn your
turn had three hearts zero masks and no
items so I selected your turn and
immediately when I did I was returned to
the Clocktower rooftop scene of my dead
link in the skull hovering above me
skullkid laughing and looping again and
again I quickly hit the reset button and
the game booted up again but there was
one more save file added below your turn
it was Ben Ben save file is right back
where it was before I delete I turned
the game off at that point I'm not
superstitious but this is way too [ __ ]
up to even for even for me I haven't
played it all today hell I didn't even
get any sleep last night I kept hearing
the reverse song of healing music in my
head and just remembering this sense of
dread I felt exploring in Clock Town I
drove back to the old man's house today
and asked to ask him some questions with
a buddy of mine no way was I going there
alone only to find that there was a for
sale sign in the front yard when I rang
the doorbell no one was home so I'm back
here now writing the rest of my thoughts
and recordings of what happened sorry if
some of this has grammatical errors and
whatnot I'm running on no sleep here I'm
terrified of this game even more so now
that I relived it a second time writing
it all down but I feel like there's more
to it than meets the eye and that
there's something calling me to
investigate this further I think Ben is
something with this in this equation but
I don't know what and if I could get a
hold of the old man then I would be able
to find some answers but I need another
day or so to recuperate before tackling
this game again it's already taken a
toll on my sanity I feel like but next
time I do this I'm going to record all
my footage the idea to record only came
to me towards the end so you'll see the
last few minutes of what it looked like
what I saw including Skull Kid in the lg
statue but it's on YouTube here I'm
going to stay in this thread for a
little while longer before I fall asleep
and answer any questions okay and then
there's a second post that's like an
update and it's there's a lot of posts
so I'm gonna read the second post should
I yeah
day 4 WMV
maybe we can link this yeah I can lick
it holy [ __ ] that's trippy dude I mean
that's like part of the game yeah I'm
scared you Beach where did it go
what a story
yeah that's right I'm gonna find it I
lost it alright let's uh let's get to
the next post sorry this is taking a
while but I think it's good I'm scared
you Beach last night everything got too
real for me I think I'm done messing
around with this I passed out pretty
much immediately after making that
thread but last night the led of
emptyness statue I had a dream about it
I dream that it was following me in my
dream that I'd be minding my own
business when I'd feel neck hair stand
up on end my neck hair stand up on end I
would turn around and that thing that
horrible lifeless statue would be
staring at me with those empty eyes
inches away
in my dream I remember calling me Ben
I've never had a dream so vividly as
that could remember so vividly being
today I put off playing the game as long
as I could I drove back to that
neighborhood to see if the old man came
back as I expected the car was still
gone and no one was home as I was
walking back to my car the man next door
mowing his grass killed the mower and
asked me if I was looking for someone I
told him I was looking to talk to the
old man that lived there today
to which he told me what I already knew
he was moving trying a different Avenue
I asked if the old man had any family or
relatives I could talk to I discovered
that this old man had never been married
nor did he have any children or
grandchildren through adoption so who
the hell's been starting to become
worried I asked one final question one
that I should have asked him beginning
who was bent
the man's expression turned grim and
learned that four doors down and I
learned that four doors down around
eight years ago on April 23rd the man
informed me that it was the same day as
his anniversary that's how he knew it
was the specific date there was an
accident with a young boy named Ben in
the neighborhood shortly after his
parents moved and despite any further
attempts to talk to the man to get more
information
he wouldn't divulge anything else I went
back and started playing again I loaded
up the game and immediately jumped in at
the title screen where the mask flies by
the sound that was playing that played
was not the normal woosh sound it was
something much more higher high-pitched
I press start bracing for the worse and
just like two nights ago the files your
turn and Ben were displayed eyebrowed
the Ben file
I'm trying to like get through this a
little quicker I'm scared to like skip a
little I'm saying I kind of want to skip
to the end okay it's very long it's
super long okay September 8th 2010 I had
a dream about that statue I dreamt that
it was following me in my dream and I
would be minding my own business when
I'd feel my neck hair stand up on it
okay yeah he wrote that I really don't
wanna play this game again I think I
think these are just like like summary
posts here I've been getting random
inexplicable headaches due to the lack
of sleep and hearing that song I'm a
head also it's flu season so I need to
be careful not to get sick my computer
just on its own opened up a text
document and wrote the words hi okay
nope WW cleverbot calm by itself what
the [ __ ] I went to the website and it's
one of those bought chatting programs
and I think it's best if I just let the
conversation speak for itself
user hello cleverbot hello user who is
this and how are you able to control my
computer clever about Who am I
user right forgot you're a bot cleverbot
do you really think that user listen I
know whoever's [ __ ] with my computer
can see my screen right now cleverbot
yes user and I'll wager that one of
those IT kids you're one of those IT
kids who thinks he's tough [ __ ]
well what you're doing right now is
legal cleverbot is it user no [ __ ] are
you familiar with terms of invasion of
privacy get the [ __ ] off my computer kid
cleverbot I am your computer use your
cool story anyway I'm calling DPS you
feel you picked a bad time to [ __ ] with
me cleverbot should I wait until you
play the game then user what clever
about the game user majora's mask clever
about yeah how did you know about that
because because what I did it did what I
played with you what what the [ __ ]
cleverbot were you scared
who the [ __ ] is this cleverbot been you
the statue you're inside my computer now
yes how you connected me how did I
connect you cables and cords tell me
about yourself what tell me about
yourself
user what do you mean what is it that
really scares you what user what the
[ __ ]
cleverbot answer no answer what the [ __ ]
how did you just open that by yourself
I am your computer now how much can you
control all what do you want from me
to entertain you're stuck inside there
you can't hurt me
cleverbot ha what the [ __ ] go play no
you can't hurt me took you long to type
that so you're not sure if you're so
powerful why use a ridiculous website
like this to chat with me less messy
more structured fun fun yeah tradition I
like it you think it's funny I'm using
in my notes you may write them down why
are you letting me it's amusing to see
what you think of me window closes so
now he starts seeing the Statue in
places internet places like he's on the
Internet he'll start to see the Statue
in places it shouldn't be mm-hmm another
conversation
answer me Ben cleverbot welcome back
what's the point of doing this why it's
amusing I wonder how you would have
reacted to what if I hadn't revealed
myself and stayed hidden only doing
little things to play with you close out
your windows turn off your computer
move your mouse by itself little things
make you wonder if I'm there but you
never know give you little hints I
wanted to do that with you you did this
before yeah and I'll do it again
to who Ben do you know Ben I won't tell
that information to you how did Ben die
cleverbot and you know no but how but
how did he drowned
I won't tell that to you why
it's reserved for another who another
who asks when later windows closed my
room is feeling different again there's
something out there
I really feel threatened like there's
something trying to reach out and
strangle me but I can't quite get there
12:46 p.m. I think Ben doesn't want to
play with me anymore I'll play again
I'll play the game again Ben can you see
this I'll play the game again just stop
please please I'm going insane trying to
decide what's real and what isn't
it's been just playing a trick on me or
is this for real has been generating
these replies or these actually postings
or is he out people actually posting
them did I just see that screen flicker
it wasn't my imagination imagining
depending on the internet and trusting
your eyes for your entire life and then
being blinded you can't rely on it
anymore you second-guess everything for
brief moments I am looking at my
responses to the videos people were
pointing out things that looked fake or
photoshopped or whatever and there's
literally no way for me to know if Ben
changed something on purpose to try to
shut me up oh my god alright it's coming
to an end let's get to September 10th
the Drowned wmv playthrough was up when
I woke up today I remember typing it up
but I don't ever remember posting it he
censored it again there's no mentioning
of the old man I have no voice anymore
I'm only posting what he wants me to I
am the mask he uses to disguise himself
as he lies there's an entire video
summary of a video that I don't remember
doing reading through the summary this
sounds morbid resembling my dream from
two nights ago except on a far more
sadistic scale these moon children there
were there's something more to them
almost as if they're another entity from
Ben something happened last night that I
can't remember I'm posting my fourth
summary to the forums now Ben won't let
me visit YouTube I can browse the rest
of the sites but he keeps exiting the
window when I go to youtube why I'm
starting to feel the air constrict I
don't feel like I'm alone here
whatever aura has been here is getting
more violent I'm trying to contact been
on cleverbot he's not responding I just
get the AI my ears aren't fooling me I'm
hearing the reverse song of healing I
keep hearing it now I'm positive I hear
it
4:23 p.m. earlier I thought it was a
weird coincidence but now I went to open
my window and three floors down at
ground level I saw the old man I'm
completely positive I did the same guy
he was just staring up in my window if
any students took knows of him they
didn't seem to acknowledge it that's
where my notes end I fled my room taking
the cartridge with me I want I don't
want to go into details of what happened
I'll lose my train of thought as I
hammer out these last details it's been
a rough two days since then this is my
last summary and service to you of the
final video you guys saw Matt WMV the
last video entry I made Matt WMV pecan
began as normal I was spawned in Clock
Town as usual and nothing seemed to be
out of place determined to set things
right and play the oath in order I
prepared myself sped up time and got to
the final day making my way to the
observatory I got to this telescope room
and approached the astronomer he would
not let me look into his telescope he
told me that I would be cheating and
that I should follow the rules despite
my repeated efforts the game would not
let me do the fourth day glitch no
matter how hard I tried it eventually
told me to go to a conic Canyon where
the game would end and it would stop
haunting me anxious and desperate to end
this nightmare I played the song of
soaring and ended up there I was told to
check my inventory that I would find
answers there in the end of the game I
arrived at the canyon and saved my
progress of the owl statue as I searched
my inventory I finally noticed that
there was a missing I was missing a
recurring song the elegy of emptiness
once I traveled there and learned the
song I remember it I suppose that was
the last thing I needed before it been
decided it had enough fun playing games
with me Ben is a manipulator he tries to
fool his victims into security and makes
you drop your guard like a Venus flytrap
then he answers them I'm nothing but a
puppet to him he enjoys seeing what kind
of human emotions he can tap into by
playing different things
I'm scared there are still some things
that don't make sense about the whole
thing but then again I was never good at
figuring these things out I'm typing
these closing thoughts on the library
computer the campus and I've emailed
myself the notes I've stored on my
infected computer from the last four
days I'm then going to combine the notes
and copy and paste them with closing and
openings that I've had on here not
taking any chances
spreading been I wouldn't wish this
horrible torment on anyone I've made
sure to have my bases covered here I
didn't run into any problems with them
and I was back on my computer trying to
email myself the notes he has no idea
what he just let me do I had no problems
opening the text document from my
infected computer on the email I can't
describe how it feels to finally be able
to get the word out about this post the
nightmare ends here that said I do not
download any of my videos or anything
about my videos through a youtube video
or audio ripper a screen grab whatever
just don't know how he can spread but I
know that just watching him on YouTube
reading my text won't allow him to
spread otherwise he would strongly he
would he would have needed my help in
the first place but I strongly recommend
you do not take anything you see
streaming online to your own personal
computer this will be my last posting
I'm putting up a form here for the world
if you see any further post for me after
today's current date September 12th and
after this current time 1208 a.m.
discredit them it's already been proven
to me that Ben can access my account
password and manipulate my computer and
I have no idea to what extent this works
he's desperate to ensure your safety
just forget about me please and
obviously this goes without saying from
here on out but do not download anything
that I've put up anything at all the
fifth day will be my last day I'm going
to burn the cartridges and then come
back to destroy my laptop again even
though I don't know you this is sort of
bittersweet for me this semester I
didn't have any friends or rather I
stopped paying attention to them but I
suppose that's partially to blame
because I'm the genius who picked to
live in a single I suppose someone in a
single I suppose someone to get a hold
of me and save me before I got too
immersed in the game would have
literally saved my life however it
proved too much for me I'm just glad it
happened to me
I could get the warnings out so that Ben
dies here lastly thank you for taking
the time to open this and open
yourselves up by believing me and
hearing my story despite despite even if
you don't believe me you didn't have to
do that really you shouldn't have your
support the entire time as kept me going
and now I'm finally free of this thanks
again
Jud usable the end I'm scared that was
very long that's kind of a crazy concept
though like someone who died and then
takes over a video game the weird thing
about that one is like yeah I think it
was made to feel real like with the with
all the the YouTube videos and stuff
like I don't know what that was hmm what
was that I don't know it's [ __ ]
creepy it was like we pulled it up on my
phone all link I'll link the whole page
but we pulled it up my phone and there's
a video of the link burning in them in
the game I've never played that game so
I don't know what it's supposed to look
like but yeah it's just after reading
the story yeah that sounds creepy and it
looks creepy mm-hmm I'm scared it is
creepy
it's creepypasta but oh yeah I mean that
was long but it was really cool I mean
it is a cool story
it's like for all the video games we
play it definitely I guess it's a ceremi
glue Ben drowned that's the name of the
story I'm just scared don't be scared
it's all fake or it's real just don't
play zelda or don't download his videos
i would say listen to what he said don't
wait don't download his videos maybe he
just doesn't want you to download his
videos yeah and he made that whole thing
up do you feel safe with that on your
head yeah well this was interesting and
fun if you guys have any this is our
first time reading any sort of
creepypasta but if you have any specific
ones you want us to read we could
totally do this again yeah it was fun I
just don't want to hear about his wet
hand ever again thank you
stop
don't touch me permit get him come you
sick falls asleep well if you stayed
that entire time thank you I appreciate
you guys hopefully you have a good rest
to your week and we'll be back next week
another podcast probably not creepy
stuff but we'll do another we'll do
another part of this if you guys want at
some point just let us know in the
comments and yeah good have a good week
we'll see on the next
[Music]